miniature models have been utilized in
the film industry for decades giving
filmmakers a cost-effective and Visually
stunning way to create sets and props
from intricate cityscapes to massive
spaceships miniature models have been
used to bring many Fantastical worlds to
life so let's take a look at some of the
best and most convincing miniature
models used in film George Lucas and his
team of model makers created some of the
most iconic miniature models in cinema
history for the original Star Wars
Trilogy from the massive Imperial Star
Destroyer to the intricate model of the
Millennium Falcon these models helped to
create a galaxy far far away that felt
real and tangible the team also created
a miniature model of the Death Star
which was used to film some of the most
iconic scenes from the franchise Ridley
Scott's dystopian Masterpiece Blade
Runner featured some of the most
visually stunning miniature models ever
the cityscape of Los Angeles in 2019 was
created using a combination of
Miniatures matte paintings and live
action footage the level of detail in
the models shows each building and
structure having a totally unique design
and like I can only imagine how many
hours it took to master that level of
detail Steven Spielberg's classic
dinosaur film used a combination of
practical effects and CGI to bring the
dinosaurs to life but the miniature
models used for some of the wide shots
were probably the most impressive the
team created a model of the parks
Visitor Center topped off with a working
waterfall and animatronic Dinosaurs the
model was used for many of the wide
shots that helped to establish the scale
of the park so of course I have to bring
up the Lord of the Rings the team at
what a workshop created miniature models
of the various cities and Landscapes
including ministereth which was over
seven feet tall Helms Deep and eisengard
they actually created thousands of
miniature models ranging in size from a
few inches to several feet tall the
level of detail in these models is just
astounding with each building and
structure clearly built to have a rich
history and backstory some other notably
impressive models used in the films were
the sets of hobbiton the Alvin city of
Rivendell and the minds of Moria and the
models were filmed using motion control
cameras and forced perspective which
allowed the filmmakers to create the
illusion of much larger and much more
complex Landscapes Christopher Nolan's
mind-bending Thriller used a ton of
realistic miniature models including a
rotating Hotel Corridor that was used to
create the film's iconic zero gravity
fight scene the model was built to scale
and rotated on a giant gimbal to create
the illusion of weightlessness the
attention to detail probably took months
with each room and hallway appearing to
be fully furnished and decorated the
miniature model of Hogwarts is one of
the most iconic examples I could talk
about it was used extensively throughout
the eight film series every inch of the
model represents 24 inches of the actual
Hogwarts Castle with each turret window
and roof tile appearing fully realized
the team spent over six months building
the model which measures 50 feet in
diameter and 12 feet in height the model
was used for a ton of key scenes
throughout the film series like the
sweeping shots of Hogwarts in the
opening and closing credits and the
exterior shots of the castle most
notably where Harry and Ron fly Ron's
Family's car through the Whomping Willow
and end up inevitably crashing it the
miniature model was also used for
several interior shots as well including
the scenes in the Great Hall and the
defense against the dark arts classroom
the team at 3D Creations created
miniature props and Furniture to fill up
the model which obviously helped create
the illusion of a full fleshed out
Hogwarts Castle so the sequel to Ridley
Scott's Blade Runner continued the
tradition of using impressive miniature
models to create a visually stunning
world the team created a miniature model
of the Wallace Corporation Headquarters
which features prominently in the film's
plot Christopher Nolan's World War II
Epic Dunkirk used a combination of
practical effects and miniature models
to recreate the famous evacuation of
Allied troops from the beaches of
Dunkirk the team created a miniature
model of the beach and surrounding area
which was used for a ton of wide shots
to help establish the scale of the
operation the model was built to scale
and was incredibly detailed with each
ship and piece of equipment appearing
authentic the dystopian Wasteland of Mad
Max Fury Road was impressively brought
to life using both practical effects and
miniature models the art department
created the miniature models of War rig
the massive tanker truck that serves as
the film's centerpiece the model was
used for a ton of wide shots including
the film's major chase scene at the end
miniature models have been a vital tool
in bringing Fantastical worlds and epic
battles to life for decades from the
Star Wars Trilogy to Dunkirk filmmakers
have used these models to create
convincing and Visually stunning sets
and props that help to immerse audiences
in their stories what was your favorite
miniature model on the list